hey guys it's benefits of a G from G
tracker here in today's video I'm gonna
show you guys how to use our candlestick
charts now one disclaimer would be that
if you're a new merchant and you're
still getting used to our site
you're still not really sure on how to
look at the charts themselves meaning
the line graphs then I wouldn't suggest
that this videos for you I would advise
that you continuously tried to improve
upon looking at the graphs and getting
comfortable with that before you start
moving on to candlestick charts now for
those of you who are comfortable with
looking at line charts then this is
obviously the next step in information
available to you as a merchant so this
is kind of getting away from that
beginner stage but one thing to keep in
mind is that this chart is very much in
beta so some of the charts aren't going
to be displaying as they're supposed to
be displaying and we are fully aware of
this problem and we're fully aware of
you know the most common bugs that this
chart may give but we are accepting any
feedback that wouldn't be commonly known
just by kind of playing around with the
site so keep that in mind when you're
using this chart if you see something
that looks out of the ordinary and just
kind of revert back to the line graph
and use the candlestick chart graph for
any other type of item that you want to
look at so to start off I wanted to show
some charts that you wanted to avoid and
some charts say you could use I feel
like this is a little bit of common
sense but I know if I don't talk about
it you guys I'm gonna bring it up in the
comments down below or an underscore
chat so here you go on the left-hand
side we have an example of a chart where
the data points are too far spaced out
and there's no information that you can
really get off of this on the right hand
side it's quite the opposite there's too
many data points bundled up together and
it doesn't look like you can get any
information off of that as well so use
your own logic guys to figure out based
off any charts you guys see in the
future but while using the sites whether
or not these are charts you guys want to
avoid or use and here are two examples
of some charts that would be okay
on both of these charts it's clearly
visible on what the information is being
presented to us so again guys use your
own logic to determine whether or not a
chart is viable for the use so what is a
candlestick chart well to answer that
question I'm going to be quoting a
paragraph off of investopedia which is
basically a website to help beginners in
learning how to trade in the real world
financial market so well runescape isn't
doesn't have the complexities of the
real world financial market it does
share some similarities however if you
were to say that the real world
financial market is the highest level
that you can achieve as a traitor then
runescape is like first grade so to
quote off this paragraph in the 1700s a
Japanese man named Homer a trader in the
futures market discovered that although
there was a link between price and the
supply and demand of rice the markets
were strongly influenced by the emotions
of traders he understood that when
emotions played into the equation a vast
difference between the value and the
price of rice occurred this difference
between the value and the price is as
applicable to stocks today as it was to
rice in Japan centuries ago the
principle is established by Homa are the
basis for the cost candlestick chart
analysis which is used to measure market
emotions surrounding a stock so you
might be saying to yourself who really
cares well it's pretty well known that
candlestick charts are pretty
off-putting and intimidating for obvious
reasons it's never really been used or
taught anywhere else except the stock
market so I felt that it's pretty
important for me to go over the
fundamentals as to why this tool was
invented in the first place if we go
back to the paragraph I just read will
learn that emotion plays a role in
determining the price of any given item
in any market which is certainly true in
runescape now if you watched my previous
video on the different types of
merchants you would have learned that
you always want to provide yourself but
the biggest edge in the market compared
to anyone else what we also learned in
the paragraph I just read is that
Callister charts are great for
determining and predicting short-term
price movement
again referring to my last video you
would have learned that making
predictions on any given item is
something that you want to continuously
work and improve on now enough about the
fundamentals of a candlestick chart
let's get into how to actually read them
so there are two different types of
candlesticks out there we have the
hollow and the filled in candlestick and
this isn't for visual preference this
actually has a valuable informational
differentiation between the other one so
I will label it off in five points here
on the left before I get into that
you'll notice that there is a long
string going through the body itself and
the rectangle on the chart now the long
string is called the shadow or the wick
and the body is called
well the rectangle is called the body
and so one would be the market high
number two is the market open number
three is the body four is the closing
price and five is the market low a
hollow candlestick chart would indicate
that sellers I can earn control but
don't let that statement confuse you all
this really means is that buyers are
opening the price at a higher amount
than what the item is closing for
meaning if I were to buy say iron ore
for 200 GP but it was actually closing
at 190 GP then this would become a
hollow candlestick chart where you would
see two being 200 GP and for being 190
GP and of course one in five are
indications of where that market was
standing throughout that entire time
frame in that period and the opposite of
that we have our solid candlestick
charts so a but number one we have our
market high number two being our market
clothes
number three being the market open and
number four being in the market low so
obviously the opposite of a hollow
candlestick charts our closing price is
much higher than our opening price which
would indicate that buyers are in
control with market but again don't let
that confuse you that's just how this is
kind of stated across any type of
platform
when it comes to candlesticks and this
would indicate a bullish market where if
this was continuously
showing on the graph with a series of
solid kennel sticks then you know that
the price is moving upwards whereas with
the hollow candlesticks if there was a
series of those together then you know
that it's a bearish markets and the
price is moving down too quickly you
reiterate what I just went over a bear
market is basically a series of a hollow
candlestick charts in which the moving
price is going down and then you have
your bull market and which is quite the
opposite of the bear market in which you
have a series of solid filled
candlesticks in which the price is
moving up now the key thing to take away
from this is that when you see these
candlestick charts the the length of the
body itself is gonna have a huge role in
indicating how quickly that mark is
gonna move in the up or a downward trend
now in the stock markets you generally
talk about the market as a whole in the
long run but runescape moves pretty
quick and price has changed quite
rapidly just like the stocks but
runescape is again like first grade so
when you're talking about the market
you're really gonna be talking about an
item in general so you could be saying
this item is acting bullish or this item
is acting bearish so novice actually
looks at some charts we can further
visualize on how to read these graphs
and use them to our advantage now as we
can see here the information is quite
clear and easily readable for us to use
so let's go over some examples of some
charts that we wouldn't be able to use
here we have a chart that's pretty
chaotic obviously we can't learn
anything off of this we have something
that's quite the opposite and then
something in between in which the data
pointer to to spread out and there's not
really anything we can learn off of this
so this is clearly something you guys
want to look for and if you guys see
anything else then just refer back to
our line graphs and
as the charts that I showed earlier you
guys to know that this chart is 100% and
still in beta so we already know that
this is an issue so don't try contacting
us in the comments down below
emailing us contacting us to discord or
on reddit letting us know that the chart
isn't working across all platforms we
already know that and we're we're
continuously trying to work on improving
it that's why it's labeled as beta but
before I get into this chart itself I
wanted to go over the fact that when you
hover over there over a data point
you're gonna get two sets of information
on the left-hand side you have your low
and high and on the right hand side you
have your opening and closing now if you
look at the left hand side of this chart
you're gonna see that there are a series
of solid bodies that are quite thin
which is gonna make the price move up in
a slow trend which is a bullish market
but it's a slow bull market and then all
of a sudden you have a series of hollow
bodies and they're pretty significant in
length which would indicate that the
price is going to move down in a quick
fashion now you might say to yourself or
ask me saying that hey there are a few
solid bodies here that are pretty
significant in length why didn't the
price continued to move up well we can
get a few a few predictions here with a
few hollow bodies that are more
significant in length than their
counterparts earlier on which is going
to help you make that prediction on
whether or not this price is going to
move down and even though we had this
one solid body here that was pretty
significant in length we had two more
shortly after which is gonna help you
guys predict whether or not this can
move up or down so keep that in mind
this had a slow bull market in the
beginning and it had a pretty heavy
bearish market soon after and then
another example we have a pretty slow
bull market in which the bodies are
pretty thin and solid and all of a
sudden we have some pretty some pretty
thick solid bodies here that made the
price move up in a very quick fashion
and then all of a sudden it kind of just
evened out between the hollow and solid
bodies
so in summary guys don't get discouraged
if this information is quite confusing
at first that's why I made a video on
this in the first place so you guys can
always refer back to this as many times
as you guys want and try and get
yourself out of that beginner an average
stage and into the mastermind category
always keep working at it and most
importantly don't give up now if you
guys want to learn a little bit more
about candlestick charts I'm gonna leave
a few links down below so you guys can
further read up on that clearly this is
something that's not not an easy topic
to talk about in a short video and I
could obviously talk about this for a
few hours but if you guys want to
further read up on that they're gonna be
in the links down below and I was gonna
include the old school runescape bond
winners from our Christmas giveaway at
the end of this video but I decided that
I wanted to keep this clutter clutter
free and keep this purely informational
so you guys always wanted refer back to
this you guys can without any worries
that you guys aren't missing out on
anything
so that's gonna be under the video guys
if you guys did like this video be sure
to leave a like down below be sure to
comment and let me know what type of
videos you guys want to see in the
future good luck merchant guys be sure
to subscribe and until next time
you